the local teen that got sick after
getting the j j vaccine is making great
progress emma berkey suffered seizures
brain surgeries and was even in a coma
over the past year but now she says she
has so much to be thankful for
i'm very grateful that i was able to get
better
because all the doctors said they didn't
think it would happen most likely not
going to be able to walk at all which i
can walk and it's great i mean it's not
as well as it was before
but i mean i'll take what i can get it's
been about 10 months since 19 year old
emma berkey got her johnson johnson
vaccine which she says caused a series
of rare health problems three brain
surgeries
five surgeries in total with my feeding
tube and my trait tube had had a total
of four strokes four bilateral strokes
so they affected both sides instead of
just one the teen is now on the road to
recovery her weekly therapy has allowed
her to stand on her own with a walker
and most recently with this cane seeing
where she's at today
she is she is a miracle emma's mom kathy
says they both got the vaccine to
protect themselves from covet 19 but
tell me they now regret that decision
when you are literally faced with the
possibility of your child not being
there the next day when they were
completely healthy
it is just gut wrenching emma says she
is one of six cases across the country
who have reportedly experienced severe
blood clocks after getting the j j
vaccine it even forced a 10-day pause on
its distribution last year until it was
determined that the benefits outweighed
the risks when you're the person that is
the risk
it matters to you it matters to your
family to the people who are going to
have to take care of you
it sucks